I asked know the Dalai Lama and I said
what do I do when I feel contempt for
another person he said show
warm-heartedness
and I thought you got anything else
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome to the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special we are eager to welcome to the
program Arthur Brooks he's the author of
a new book love your enemies he's also
the head of the American Enterprise
Institute we'll get to his new book and
all sorts of life-changing topics in
just a second but first getting life
insurance can feel like assembling the
world's worst jigsaw puzzle it's
confusing it takes forever and when
you're finally done it doesn't even look
very cool if you have a mortgage kids or
anyone who depends on your income this
is a puzzle you need to solve policy
genius can help you do it policy genius
is the easy way to get life insurance in
just two minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find the best
policy for you when you apply online the
advisors of policy genius will handle
all the red tape for you they will even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
companies that means no Commission sales
agents no hidden fees just helpful
advice and personalized service policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also make it easy to find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance they're your
one-stop-shop for financial protection
so if you find life insurance puzzling
head on over to policy genius calm in
two minutes you can compare quotes find
the right policy save up to 40% doing it
I know you don't want to think about
life insurance you don't want to think
about death but the fact is if you're a
responsible person you need to make sure
that your family is taken care of and
got in case god forbid something should
happen to you go get a life insurance
policy right now go check out policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance Arthur thanks so much for
stopping by I really appreciate it thank
you van I'm just so happy to be here I
got to tell you my I have teenage kids I
have two sons one's the junior of
Princeton and one is a farmer in Idaho
and they both think you're cooler than I
am well that's that's very flattering
and I really appreciate it well you know
your book is called love your enemies
and it says how decent people can save
America from the culture of contempt and
I have to get the elephant in the room
out of the way immediately which is that
people are gonna be asking how is it
that Ben Shapiro of ben shapiro destroys
blank favor could possibly be
interviewing you and taking seriously
the question of loving your enemies
people who disagree with you and so i
want to go through sort of what you mean
by loving your enemies and also what is
the best way to do that in a
frog culture so let's start with with
the basics how did you come up with this
idea that the biggest problem we have in
the culture is us not loving our enemies
well as I'm looking around and look
we've been we've been going through the
same trials and the same tribulations
those of us were on the political right
we've seen a lot of bad things happen
we've seen just that this the way that
the whole discourse has been spoiled and
not just by people on the other side by
people under on our own side as well I
thought to myself you know what's the
big problem and people say well we need
more civility or we mean we need more
tolerance that's garbage we don't need
more civility I mean if I said hey Ben
you know my wife Esther and I were civil
to each other you'd be like oh man dude
you need some counseling
or you know my employees at the American
Enterprise Institute they tolerate me
it's a bad scene yeah these are not high
enough standards basically I started
thinking to myself what do we need well
when you go back to the sacred texts but
the the pillars of philosophy in the
West what you find is that there's this
subversive teaching which is basically
to love your enemies this comes from the
you know the the Gospel of st. Matthew
the fifth chapter the 44th verse where
Jesus tells his followers to love their
enemies why well Martin Luther King
actually sorted it out for the modern
ear when you love your enemies you find
out they weren't your enemies after all
you know people will say that you know
when they look at the Internet they say
you know Ben Shapiro destroys one of the
things I happen to know is you're not
using that language and when I watch you
up on stage you're tough you're going
hammer and tongs after the people who
disagree with you but by and large I
think that you're engaging with ideas
and not treating the people with
contempt and I admire that could you be
better could I be better for sure but in
point of fact I think we're going in the
same direction I think we're trying to
make progress in the same way so let's
talk about what it means to for someone
to be your enemy so you make the point
in the book that there are people who
are obviously their enemies where I mean
they're obviously Islamofascist they're
they're members of the Taliban are those
people that we should should love I mean
how do we deal with are there gradations
in other words to the enemies that we
ought to love are there the domestic
political enemies meaning you know
president Trump's enemy of the people
press and Democrats versus Republicans
or are there like a legitimate group of
people that it's that it's okay not to
love there are gradations of course and
in the main point that I'm making here
what I'm talking about how decent
can save America from the culture of
contempt I'm largely talking for an
American audience for we have started to
just suffer from something that
political science scientists call motive
attribution asymmetry big fancy terms so
that you academics like making it tenure
but basically what it means is that that
when you feel that you're motivated your
ideology by love but the other side is
motivated by hatred now this is
something you typically see in the
palestinian-israeli conflict but what
political scientists are finding for the
very first time is a Democrats from
Republicans conservatives and liberals
are displaying the same level of
motivation as attribution asymmetry as
the Israelis and the Palestinians in
other words we're treating each other
internally in American politics as the
other as the enemy and this is not anger
anger is fine
anger is literally not correlated with
separation and divorce among married
couples the problem is contempt the
conviction of the utter worthlessness of
the other person that's what we see and
so I'm talking to a largely American
audience this is obviously has
gradations we're talking about warfare
and people overseas that want to kill us
but I'm telling you what I'm looking at
as somebody in the political left in the
United States I can disagree but that
person should not be treated with
contempt not by me not by you not by
anybody watching us and if we can get
past that that is the source of our
strength and I'll admit when I read the
book I mostly see my own shortcomings in
and things that I can do better and you
tell the story in the book of the first
time that you sort of experience the the
use of love in order to overcome what
you felt was somebody who is attacking
you and somebody who wrote you a long
email going after one of your previous
books and how you're spotted that
wonderful might want to tell it so yeah
so I mean this is this is having a long
time ago and it was I was actually I
recalled this because I asked neither
than the Dalai Lama
I was making this documentary film and
and I said what do I do when I feel
contempt for another person he said show
warm-heartedness and I thought you got
anything else
it seemed sort of weak to me but then I
remember dali lama's a tough a tough
person he he was exiled as a teenager
from his homeland and Tibet he was just
rolled over by the Communist Chinese and
he spent every day for the last six
decades starting each morning praying
for the Communist Chinese leaders that
they'll live good and happy lives that's
toughness and a nice and I said well I
I do that and he said remember a time
when you accidentally do did it so I
thought back to 2006 I was a professor
at Syracuse University in those days and
and I had just written a book it written
a lot of books that nobody never read
them because they were very boring and I
was a you know I was living a happy
professorial existence and I wrote this
one book that hit the news cycle in just
the right way I think President Bush
read it and and it got into the news and
I was on the news every day it was weird
happens to academics sometimes sort of
selling hundreds of copies a day my life
changed kind of permanently as a matter
of fact and the weirdest part is I
started to get emails from people I'd
never met so I get an email from a guy I
mean hundreds then when when you have a
book you know how this feels when you
have a book that that's selling people
feel like they know you and if they
don't like your book they don't like you
so I started getting emails from people
I loved your book can tell you about my
grandma you know that kind of stuff my
email was very easy to get and I heard
from people who didn't like it as well
okay two week sessions book comes out
and get an email from a guy in Texas
your professor Brooks you are a
right-wing fraud bad way to start him
out but I keep reading and I noticed
this email is like 2,000 words long no
more 5,000 words can it take me 20
minutes to read this email but as I'm
reading it you know and I'm you know I'm
game and he's insulting everything like
did you know that that I think that the
columns are in 3 table 3.1 or reversed
you idiot stuff like this as I'm reading
through the email this thing is going
through my head he read my book I was
filled with gratitude
why because I had it taken me two years
to write it and he'd read every word so
I decided you know I'm just gonna tell
what's written on my heart I got nothing
to lose I'm never gonna see him
so I read him back you're so and so it
took me two years to write that book I
put my whole heart into it you read
every word I'm so grateful to you thank
you send and then I go back to work 15
minutes later his his response pops back
up Bing opened up the email
dear professor Brooks next time you're
in Texas if you want to get some dinner
give me a call huh that's power what it
turns out was that it look it took me a
long time to remember that because I was
stimulated in that memory by His
Holiness the Dalai Lama but once I did I
never forgot I remember the feeling of
not just a power but of warmth you know
and his point is when somebody treats
you with contempt and been man you're
going to be treated with contempt
next time you go out in public like I've
seen it and and and you're super good at
responding to ideas but you're gonna be
treated the contempt you're gonna get a
choice
I can answer with contempt or I can
answer with love no no no the answer
with love does not mean to agree with
the person we have a responsibility to
say what we think why because ideas have
consequences and misguided ideas have
deleterious consequences for society but
when you answer somebody with whom you
disagree with enough respect to show
them the disagreement and to do it with
love you'll change at least one heart
and that bends heart and that's Arthur's
heart and maybe maybe the other person
start as well so what do you do when
somebody comes at you and it's not just
a contemptuous argument about your ideas
what if somebody comes at you and the
way that people have tended to do this
lately
is to call you legitimately morally
deficient so you give the example of
you're somebody who is pro-gun rights
and the implication is put forward after
Sandy Hook that the reason that you are
pro-gun rights is because you don't care
enough about dead children or the reason
that you believe what you believe on
welfare policy is because you're a
vicious racist how should you respond to
that how is it possible to be warm
hearted now I'll admit my typical
strategy when someone calls me a racist
is to say well you're acting like a
jackass you have no evidence that I'm a
racist obviously you are now acting like
a jackass because attacking people
without evidence makes you such but
that's pretty hostile way to do it but
it feels like the only way sometimes to
shake people out of the stupor of
slandering people with those sorts of
names and I also am worried that if I
say listen let me explain you all the
reasons why I'm not a racist I've
already lost the argument I can't grant
credibility to even the statement
because the statement is so off base
what's the best way to handle something
so yeah when somebody says you're a
racist or you know prove to me you're
not a racist it's like it's when did you
stop beating your wife I mean it's just
it's a it's an unanswerable question
because the premise is entirely wrong
okay now the first thing to remember is
that in point of fact the person is
behaving like a jackass your and and
you're utterly within your rights to say
so but that misses a core opportunity
you take the person on very very
vigorously but in terms that basically
says I understand the position that
you're coming from which is that you
have a huge concern about a racism in
our society and I share that concern
with you don't even take on the charge
that Ben Shapiro's a racist that's
idiotic and everybody knows it but the
opportunity
this look when you're on a college
campus or you're in the media in them in
the mainstream media and people are
watching there are a ton of people out
there they're not hostile they're also
not true believer doesn't Bend Shapiro
you got a ton of true believers but a
lot of people are not there persuadable
they're open they're skeptical but
they're open how are those people going
to be persuaded they're gonna be
persuaded by the force not just of the
the the force of your arguments but the
way that you make those arguments the
mercy that emanates from your heart the
love that you actually show the respect
that you show for other Americans look
those people were attacking you they're
not all bad people they're really
concerned about legitimate things they
just don't know how to express it in the
right way and they've never gotten
proper direction to treat another human
being with with respect so you can turn
it around and say look I don't like the
way you just talk to me
but I do share the concerns that are
written on your heart so I'm gonna talk
about those concerns because I think
I've got a better way to address them
that maybe even you do but at very least
I want you to consider those things
who's gonna be watching that they're
persuadable people in the audience
they're gonna go huh ben shapiro no
horns man I don't know more so one of
the things that you talk about and love
your enemies is the fact that are the
amount of contempt in our politics has
been rising very very rapidly of recent
vintage do you think that that's a
result of the polarization of politics
or do you think that polarization in
politics is a result of the contempt I
feel like it's a bit of a chicken or the
egg question yeah I think it's what it's
what economists would call an endogenous
situation where one is actually causing
the other and we're in a vicious cycle
and that again once again is a big
opportunity because once you you you you
cut the cycle it's no longer downwardly
spiraling and it requires the people who
are in the public eye I mean I have I'm
very blessed to be in a position where I
get to talk in public you even more and
you have millions of people who are
watching this show and you can actually
cut that cycle of contempt and show
other people more importantly how to do
it because you know what you say people
are gonna I'm gonna they're gonna follow
you because you're a leader under the
circumstances so sure polarization leads
to contempt contempt leads to more
polarization this is actually how all
relationships deteriorate I have a
friend his name is John Gottman he
teaches the University of Washington
he's the world's leading expert in
marital reconciliation he guy's a hero
he's brought thousands of people back
together who would have otherwise gotten
divorced and one of the things that one
of the many things you and I agree on is
that the a good society must
based on stable happy families that are
better have love for each other so this
guy I mean he really is a modern-day
hero and he notes that that what
predicts divorce is not anger at all I
mean thank God I married to a Spaniard
no arguments told me the divorce or that
thousands and thousands of over the past
twenty eight years
what relieves the divorce is treating
other people like you have contempt for
that person i Rowling sarcasm
contemptuous humor derisive jokes these
are the things that really predict
divorce I mean John Gottman can counsel
somebody for an hour counsel a couple
for an hour and know with more than 90%
accuracy if they'll be divorced within
three years by looking for those signs
of contempt and those are the same
things that destroy relationships at all
different levels friendships collegial
relationships and in point of fact
that's what's happening in America today
that's the reason that people can't talk
to each other that one in six Americans
have literally stopped talking to a
close friend or family member because of
the election of 2016 that's that's way
worse than politics that's a crisis of
love when it comes to this this problem
of contempt one of the one of the
questions I guess I have is that it's
very tied I think to humor so if you
wanted to look at you know the chief
progenitors of contempt in American
politics I really wouldn't look to our
politicians first I'd look to somebody
like John Stewart because Jon Stewart
spent years basically showing a clip of
somebody making a face at that person
and then that was the cue for the
audience to laugh now we all enjoy that
is there a way to separate out humor
from contempt or is it just we need to
stop treating politics as entertainment
more generally well there's nothing
wrong with humor the problem is mockery
and mocking another person is trying to
hurt that person that's trying to
belittle that other person and and it's
really tempting yes I give in to
temptation regularly I do - I do - you
know guilty you know and look I and one
of the things that stimulated this book
love your enemies as I saw myself on TV
behaving with contempt and treating
somebody with mockery using humor I mean
I've been telling jokes my whole life I
was like the I was the the the
wisecracking kid in the back of the
class when I was growing up I mean it
that's the reason it took me to all
those 38 graduate from college that's so
the story and and okay and I saw myself
doing I thought that's not right that is
that actually is I'm not living up to my
own values I mean these people or
they disagree with me but there they're
not evil and they're certainly not
stupid and and you know the key moment
came for me been and and I'm sure you've
had this experience - I was at this this
political activist rally in 2014 a
couple years before the 2016 election
and you know I do a ton I did like a
hundred and seventy-five speeches a year
I'm on the road all the time being the
president of a think tank is like not
much thinking and tanks on the road
sitting on planes and I was talking to
this group of activists tonight and I
said in my talk you know I want you to
remember look we agree I said to this
group you know they were they were very
conservative I said we agree on you can
AMA policy in foreign policy but I want
you to remember the people who are not
here because they don't agree their
political progressives and I want you to
remember they're not stupid they're not
evil
they're just Americans who disagree with
us on politics and there's a lady
afterwards she said actually they're
stupid and evil but I thought to myself
that's not where I want to be because I
can't make progress I'm in the business
of persuading people so that we can get
more dignity so that people can be
lifted up in their dignity and so we can
explore the limitlessness of human
potential that's what America is
supposed to be all about that's what our
culture is really that's why that the
Shapiro's why I suppose three
generations ago we're probably like
bailing out of some godforsaken shtetl
someplace and and you know come in
someplace where they could build their
lives they wanted someplace where they
had radically equal human dignity and
and and the Brooks is - by the way who
are moving west one step ahead of law
and and now look at you and me I mean we
actually get to sit here talking about
ideas in front of hundreds of thousands
or millions of people what a privilege
we can't waste it we got to bring people
in and show them the blessing that
really is this country that's the point
of your new book which is such an
important book a blessing of what the
West really can bring and and how we can
celebrate these ideas to lift other
people up on a second I wanna ask you
about the efficacy of contempt because I
want to ask you there's an ax market
advantage to contempt I'll get to that
in just one second but first hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go where hiring is simple and fast
and smart it's a place where growing
businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place is zip recruiter
dot-com / been guest because I have a
guest
zip recruiter sends your job to over 100
of the web's leading job boards but
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you're
never gonna miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective that 80%
of employers who post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day and right now
my listeners can try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash been guest that zip
recruiter comm /b and GU est zip
recruiter comm slash been guest zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire and
it is the best way to hire you don't
have to post 100 job boards just use zip
recruiter comm slash been guest that zip
recruiters a calm / been guest zip
rocker is indeed the smartest way to
hire alright so when it comes to
contempt
finally obvious faster move exactly when
it comes to contempt the fact is that
there is a feeling in modern American
politics that contempt is effective
business that that an ounce of contempt
can destroy a bevy of arguments and
contempt for ideas particularly can help
destroy a bevy of arguments so you don't
know it's a short hand you can just skip
the the argument entirely or you can
just completely just destroy a an actual
idea through use of contempt and thereby
leaving that out of your arsenal you're
basically surrendering to the other side
and I think that that's where you're
seeing a lot of the passion come from on
the right particularly when you have
folks who are being hit with the
intersectional identity politics or
group politics being called racist
sexist pig and homophobes and they just
want to say listen socialism is dumb
socialism is evil
are there some ideas that are so bad in
other words that they have earned
contempt even in the current
contemporary debate youth there are lots
of ideas that have earned contempt to be
sure but there are no people in America
who Vernick and so how do we distinguish
that because I really want to dig in on
this because I think that we live in a
time where ideas are so tight into our
own identity and we've convinced
ourselves really since the 60s that the
personal is the political right and that
my politics are me so if you and I
disagree on tax rates and then I attack
tax rate your tax policy and I think I
say you know that I think it's a foolish
tax policy I think it's falling apart
everywhere it's tried then you take that
as a personal affront and now my
contempt for your idea has been
interpreted as contempt for you
is there a way around that there is and
the there is absolutely because the
personal isn't the political ideas are
not people I people have ideas and ideas
can change society and they really
affect people a lot but but the most
important thing is that we are
autonomous individuals that we are
people that we can generate ideas and
until we can separate out people from
ideas we're gonna continue in this
really terrible cycle so how do we do
that we by modeling that there's an
incredible source of power now it's much
easier they go contemptuous on a
particular person and to destroy a
particular person but let's remember
it's ultimately a self-defeating
proposition if we're trying to bring
more people into our way of thinking
what it does is it locks down our
particular base we have a president
United States who's good at base locking
we have his entire opposition of the
Democratic Party all you know 57,000
people who are running for president and
the Democratic ticket at this point all
but a couple are basically using the
same rhetorical techniques as President
Trump but that's an ultimately
self-defeating proposition because what
you've got is warring tribes
you're never gonna actually bring people
into a meaty coalition of those who
share certain values such that we can
make progress until you can persuade
other people what does that take that
takes leadership by guys like you and me
people who actually have an audience of
people out there who are listening the
way the way that we communicate with
other people who see us pass the on the
opportunity to treat other people with
contempt to vigorously assert the the
correctness or incorrectness of
particular ideas I'm not saying we have
to agree on the contrary agreement least
a mediocrity and stagnation it's like
it's a kind of a monopoly you know
countries where everybody agrees they go
no place we believe in competition in
markets and in politics that's called
democracy and sports and especially the
competition of ideas when something's
wrong you got to say it when something's
dangerous you have to articulate that
but separating that out from the
individual now is showing love toward
the individual that's a true source of
strength it's hard to do it's hard to do
I'm trying to do it that's why I wrote
the book but when you can do that and
when I can do that people will follow
and that's the beginning of a movement
it seems like a lot of that is really
tied down to interpersonal contact
meaning that it's much easier to have
conversations with people in person via
phone than it is over social media
social medias seems
a machine for spinning up content
especially Twitter where you've got 280
characters now to say what you've got to
say get it off your chest
I remember there was a situation
recently where I got into a little bit
of Mines me with Pete but a geek who's
one of the guys running for president on
the Democratic side one of the 57,000
and it started to go sideways and a
certain point I said want just come on
the Sunday special I'm glad we engaged
and suddenly it was diffused because it
was an actual invite we do it
is he gonna he's not reached out I've
asked him well we'll see if he does I'd
love to have mod I mean really we're
always looking for Democrats to come on
but they are afraid specifically of the
kind of antipathy that they think
they're gonna receive or maybe they just
don't want to be challenged but I'm
happy to have folks on the Democratic
Left on on the show for sure but it was
it was that feeling of defusing that
came from I had a name he had a name
he's talking the book about the culture
of anonymous social media and how
counterproductive it is to the kind of
anti contempt you're looking for I was
hoping maybe you could talk a little bit
about that yeah for sure so I'm on
social media you're on social media you
have tons of people who are following
you on social media and there's a real
temptation when we're on social media
and in you know we're dealing with
one-on-one people we have lots of
friends we have lots of people who
disagree with us you know if I were to
ask everybody watching us today how many
of you love somebody with whom you
disagree politically all the hands would
go up and that's I mean I hope I mean
practically all the hands except for the
people who are not listening or we're
not getting out of the house enough and
yet on social media we D what's what
political scientists are what social
scientists called deindividuation or
it's dehumanization we dehumanize
ourselves by becoming anonymous and as
such we lower our moral standards and
there were we're here in in in in Los
Angeles area I live in Washington DC and
one of the big problem that we have is
people are terrible to each other in
traffic I've got a way where I could
solve that where everybody has to put
their name on a bumper sticker on the
back of the car and their house of
worship wow I just got flipped off by
you know Mike Smith from Our Lady of
Sorrows so you know so the problem that
we have on social media is the ultimate
traffic problem where people D
individuate themselves they dehumanize
themselves they lower their moral
standards and they engage in behavior
they don't like well well then they're
there they're gearing it towards people
who really are publicly putting forth
their their their actual identity ben
shapiro
Arthur Brooks and so the tendency is for
us to say well that jerk not only is he
wrong he's rude and so I'm gonna come
back at him I'm gonna come back at him
hard but in so doing what you've done is
you've taken on a phantom you've taken
on somebody who doesn't actually exist
so one of the things that I recommend I
mean for the self-preservation of these
social media companies they're gonna
have to stop giving platforms to
anonymous users because little by little
people are figuring out the social media
is no fun is decrementing their
happiness good studies show that more
hours in social media less happiness and
by the way that's also true for Ben and
Arthur oh yeah thank God for Sabbath for
sure for sure on Friday night and
Saturday night all that goes off maybe
four days seven really yes so that's
important I've had these exact
conversations my wife how do I minimize
the number of hours that I'm actually on
Twitter because there is definitely an
inverse proportion between the amount of
time on Twitter and human happiness
there know for sure absolutely you feel
your chest tightening and you know
people what they don't understand is you
know they're just some guy sitting on
his sofa and he's called Bernie bro 2020
or something and he goes after ben
shapiro well you know ben shapiro was a
flesh-and-blood guy you know and Arthur
Brooks has got actual feelings and and
what we we get used to it so it's kind
of okay but in point of fact it's it's a
mistake for us to in to engage at all
with people who are anonymous because
you're going after people that in a very
real way in a very human way they don't
exist you gotta love your enemies by
which I mean people who it turns out
we're enemies but those are people and
people who will not divulge their
identities or give part of anything
anything of their humanity anything of
their story they're saying I'm actually
not a human being for all you know it's
a Russian Twitter bot and and so not
worth engaging so in your book you talk
about talks a little bit here about the
gradations in terms of you know who's
worthy of contempt so the Taliban worthy
of contempt but you know in the United
States the idea is that we are well we
think that we may be enemies we're
actually not enemies we're brothers in
the link in sort of laconian formulation
I want to ask if that's really true and
the reason now and ask that is because
as certain people on both sides become
more radical I think right now the left
is moving in a radical direction faster
than the right is Donald Trump is
actually in policy somewhat of a
moderate Republican the left seems to be
moving pretty dramatically in a far left
and direction including embrace of
democratic socialism you talk about
these sort of moral Val
use that you still think unite Americans
what do you think those moral values are
and are you are you overstating the case
do you think that we have more in common
than we may actually have in common I
may be overstating the case but I want
to err on that side
why because one of the things that I've
noticed is that leaders throughout
history who are truly aspirational
they're not populist getting a populism
is fundamentally not leadership it's
followership
it's basically and you've made this
point a hundred times like I stole this
from ben shapiro but there's a there's a
parade going down the street a populist
is a guy who says there's a parade I'd
better get out in front of it they need
a leader leadership is something that
says there's a better future can you see
it there's a guy who teaches at Harvard
Business School named named Daniel
Goleman and he talked about
authoritative leadership which is not
you must come with me it's not coercive
it says do you see a better future do
you want it and maybe people don't want
it but in point of fact you have to look
at the horizon you have to look at the
moral horizon you have to say this is
something better and to hold Americans
to their highest and best values that's
a good thing to do are we there no am i
there not every day but I want to be
there and I want America to be there and
so I'm looking for what I think is kind
of the moral DNA of this country and the
moral Dee in this country unambiguously
believes in the radical equality of
human dignity why because you make this
point in your new book everybody's got
to get this book because it talks about
how how these have these judeo-christian
values these Western values are a gift
to the world people even if they're not
religious and you want a lot of people
watching us who are atheists were
secular completely but they believe in
the quality of human dignity why because
we have a culture that's based on the
idea that each one of us has made in
God's image God is worthy of respect
that's the essence of dignity and so
each one of us is worthy of dignity
that's what Americans actually believe
furthermore the reason that they you
know the people came here in the first
place is because we believe in the
limitlessness of human potential so
let's call Americans the dignity and
potential are they living up to it No
will they ever live up to it completely
not my lifetime but I'm gonna work
in a social movement in an intellectual
movement and in a media movement I'm
gonna work with you we're gonna work
together to try to help Americans live
up to those standards even though we
haven't hit him yet I mean I certainly
agree with all
that I wonder if there are active
opponents to some of that and the reason
I say that is because you put you point
out Jonathan heights moral matrix
Jonathan's been on the program professor
height and he and we talked about the
the five factors maybe six if you
include liberty would be added later and
you talk about how conservatives end and
liberals still believe in a couple of
them the session earnest compassion and
fairness but even those ones as
professor Hyde has recognized our seen
an almost diametrically opposed way so
fairness for conservatives is fairness
in the meritocratic sense the idea that
we all have the equal rights but that
the outcome is not going to be equal and
fairness for many on the Democratic side
is fairness of outcome which is directly
opposed to fairness of meritocracy right
when it comes to compassion on the right
side of the aisle the value system tends
to be while compassion is me helping you
find a job develop a skill set care for
yourself and compassion on the left side
of the aisle is how do I create a system
whereby you don't have to care for
yourself whereby we are caring for you
that's that's real compassion so if
that's the case then even the most basic
values the ones that are necessary for
us to be playing the same game so to
speak have those been radically
undermined or do you think that there
are bridges that can still be built I
think there are bridges and the reason
is because let's take something like
fairness where the right really does
focus on meritocratic fairness it's
don't take something that somebody else
earned and the left really does focus
much more redistribute of fairness the
idea of redistributing somebody has more
somebody has less the person who has
left less needs more you take it from
the person who has more okay I got it
but that doesn't mean that you and I who
are guys on the center-right are on the
right don't believe in any new
redistribution that's wrong you believe
that there should be a welfare state and
so do i I mean I I believe that the the
free enterprise system one of the
greatest accomplishments ever the free
enterprise system was their ability to
support people we've never even met it's
incredible thing that no system in
history has been able to accomplish
because of capitalism it's because of
the largesse that came from capitalism
and it's such a blessing I'm so proud of
it and that means I believe in some
amount of redistribution I'm just more
meritocratic in that balance you know I
know a ton of people on the Left I have
tons of friends and family I mean I used
to be a musician and college professor
and I come from Seattle Washington for
pete's sake I know a lot of people on
the left and and they don't they don't
think that merits garbage they think
that merits great because they want
their kids to achieve and and they're
kind of
I would live in a country where people
can start companies and do great things
they just they want a little bit more
redistribution now you find radicals and
and when I say this I mean that the set
approximately depending account at the
7% of people who are true polarizing
radicals in this country who don't see
any common ground but if 93% of us give
or take actually do believe that there
can be some common ground that we can
work together in some way shape or form
that I'm going to be bridging that
meritocratic redistribute of divide and
I'm gonna be really forgiving I'd only
be as generous as I possibly can to the
people who don't agree quite as much
with my meritocratic values so I can try
to get some fairness that bridges that
gap and I think it can be done okay so
in a second I want to ask you where you
came from because your story is really
fascinating and I want people to hear
how you got from French horn to what you
do now but first when the founders
crafted the Constitution the very first
thing they did was to make sacred the
rights of the individual to share their
ideas without limitation by their
government the second right they
enumerated was the right of the
population to protect that speech and
their own persons with force you know
how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different Bravo
company manufacturing was started in a
garage by a Marine veteran more than two
decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they're a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment they
assume that each rifle leaving their
shop will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or soldier oversees
every component of a BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard BCM feels a moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that are not going to fail the
user when it's not just a paper target
but somebody actually coming to do them
harm BCM works with leading instructors
of marksmanship from top levels of
America's Special Operations Forces who
can teach the skills necessary to defend
yourself your family or others to learn
more about Bravo company manufacturing
head on over to Bravo Company MFG comm
that's where you can discover more about
their products special offers and
upcoming news that is Bravo Company MFG
comm you can also check them out over at
YouTube at youtube.com slash Bravo
Company USA Bravo Company
Manufacturing fantastic company so I
want to ask you about your personal
story because as a person who also grew
up as a classical musician your story is
pretty amazing I mean you started off as
a musician in Spain playing the French
horn and here you are doing public
policy and data analysis how'd you get
from one place to the other it's it's
not the typical path and it's certainly
not linear I mean when you say how do
you become the president of a big
national think tank the answer is not
you know play the French horn I started
when I was classical music when I was
four years old I played you know this is
a typical story I mean you're you're
from the arts too I started violin when
I was four piano when I was five French
horn which I was really good at it turns
out when I was nine and from that moment
I wanted to be the world's greatest
French horn player that was my was my
real ambition I just grew up wanting to
do this when I was 19 I was in college I
spent a little less than one year in
college was the California Institute of
the Arts right here outside last night
outside Los Angeles in Valencia up in
the Santa Clarita Valley it was a pretty
unrewarding experience I think not just
for me but also it's pretty unrewarding
for the institution and they they they
they they offered me an opportunity to
earn my success elsewhere and so I I
went out on the road as a professional I
started playing chamber music all around
the United States I did that for about
seven months a year from 19 News when I
was 25 I played a couple of years with a
jazz guitar player named Charlie Bird we
had a group called bird and brass which
is fantastic and when I was 25 I got a
job in the Barcelona Orchestra and so I
and the reason actually I did that by
the way it was a total startup endeavor
I met a girl and and I met her when I
was on a tour in Europe and she lived in
Barcelona and the only way I was gonna
have a bid at trying to you know I was
gonna I had to go all in had to quit my
job move to a place where I never
learned the language and I've known her
for a week at this point but you know I
called it my desk dad this gives you a
little bit in the insight into the you
know the Warped I said dad I met the
girl thing I'm gonna marry it's great
not so great she doesn't live in United
States she doesn't speak a word of
English and she doesn't know this and I
don't want a restraining order anyway so
I quit my job I moved to Spain joined
the Barcelona Orchestra and we're about
to celebrate our 20th wedding
anniversary okay so it totally did we
have three kids two of whom are
teenagers but I'm not here to tell you
my problems anyway as I said there
you're big fans of bencher
so that's gracious that's great stuff
but when I got to Barcelona I thought to
myself you know I want to do something
more I dropped out of college that kind
of bugged me I got nothing against not
going to college that's all kinds of
good lives can happen without going to
college but but for me I kind of felt
like I screwed it up and I'd failed so I
went back and started studying by my
correspondence and I got my bachelor's
degree in economics and I had this weird
epiphany this is why I love your new
book so much because it really spoke to
me it reminded me of this epiphany I had
in my late 20s when I was studying for
my bachelor's degree I took economics
for the first time and I and I learned
this crazy thing that 80% of the world's
poverty had been eradicated since I was
a kid you know I thought that hunger was
worse I thought that the world was worse
and furthermore I thought capitalism was
great for rich people and bad for poor
people and you know and I grew up in a
left-wing environment and I didn't knew
nobody who cared about economics or
business but I was learning that two
billion of my brothers and sisters had
been pulled out of poverty since I was a
child and I learned that it came from
five things five things and all
economists left right and center this is
not controversial stuff this is not this
is propaganda
five things pulled two billion of Ben
and Arthur's brothers and sisters out of
poverty since 1970 was globalization
free trade property rights the rule of
law and the culture of free enterprise
spreading from America all around the
world I thought huh you know you know my
favorite composer in those days was
Johann Sebastian Bach you know the
greatest composer ever lived and he was
asked near the end of his life why do
you write music his answer was the aim
and final end of all music is nothing
less than the glorification of God and
the refreshment of the soul I thought to
myself how can I answer like Bach it
wasn't answering like boxes of French
horn player in the orchestra I thought I
want to do something that glorifies God
and it refreshes the lives of other
people and I became an economist Bach
made me into an economist and then I you
know I got my PhD I taught for ten years
and then I became president of the the
greatest thing tank in the world the
American Enterprise Institute where
people fight every day for dignity for
potential and and who believed that that
the frame
price system is America's gift of the
world but in an artistic way because the
fact is that unlike most economists you
are you're a story driven person you
talk about this in love your enemies
the idea that story is really what
connects us and well you can know all
the stats that you want to know in the
end what's really going to allow you to
connect to other people is the ability
to identify with them with them on a
one-to-one level yeah absolutely
you know is it the truth is it's funny
you know and when you're trained as an
economist you start believing that the
force of your arguments is gonna win
people over and I wish it did because
that I I know I lost arguments for you
know 15 years you know people would talk
to me about the minimum wage I would say
don't you understand supply and demand
and you're raising the the cost of labor
and you did threaten people would say
you know just a hard-hearted
something something and you just want to
you know put more you know dollars in
the the CEO of Walmart's pocket or
something and I thought no until I
realized I needed to tell a human story
look I mean the people who really want
to fight for a higher minimum wage god
bless them they have a really good
intention you know there was a long time
when people in the political left
weren't fighting to make work pay and
people who want a higher minimum wage
they're fighting to make work pay that's
a really good objective until they
finally have enough generosity to say
that's an excellent objective I
completely agree with it because work
brings purpose work brings meaning
you've had micro in your show work
brings dignity in every single job every
single job is a blessing and it's good
there's no dead-end jobs right so it's
okay so I really respect that particular
objective of the people who want to who
want to increase the minimum wage
they're just worried about the ability
of people at the minimum wage to be able
to support themselves and their families
I'm worried about that too let's talk
about a better way to get it done that
doesn't impair all the people at the
very bottom of the of the wage ladder to
keep their jobs
let's find better policies and let's
find more open economic systems let's
share the objective and let's let's
differ let's have a competition of ideas
about the way to actually meet that
objective
that's stories about real people and
that's rocked my world man that's
completely changed my work well you talk
a lot in the book at least the beginning
about the 2016 election what you think
happened there what drove president
because Trump breaks a lot of these
rules right president Trump is is a
master of the use of contempt it drips
from everything that he says he can be
vicious and brutal and very effective in
his political warfare and you talk
specifically about sort
a group of folks who you believe felt
dispossessed by current politics and
we're looking for a leader to kind of
restore a feeling for them and you
specifically are talking about non
college educated white males where do
you think the situation is with non
college educated white males and it
seems like if you're anti contempt what
do people across the spectrum including
this group of people need to need to
think of it yeah that's a great question
something that I've contemplated a lot
what did I get wrong and I know that
you're not this huge fan of President
Trump yet we're both trying to
understand the dynamics of what's going
on in the United States oh we can help
our country you know for the people on
the Left have always said there's this
income gap and people on the right of
Ellis said there's an opportunity gap
and and both things factually exist but
the real thing that we missed was the
dignity gap in this country you know
ever since the beginning of the war on
poverty which did amazing things and
raising the standard of living I mean if
you go into the poorest places in the
United States you don't have a calorie
deficit everyone's got running water you
know they have enough space to live in
but the truth of the matter is that it's
basically that that system in our
culture has said to poor people we don't
need you the basis of dignity is to be
needed to be needed by your family to be
needed by your community and and
indirectly to be needed by the economy
we forgot that we've been moving away
from that for a long time that was
exploded that was exacerbated massively
by the financial crisis of 2008 and
people who in positions of authority and
power they didn't seem to understand
that there was a dignity gap and when
people feel that they are not needed man
they're gonna fight back they want
somebody who's gonna fight for them you
know Donald Trump his ideas may have
been good they made it might have been
bad his ideas about you know I'm
standing in front of a coal mine or a
steel plant saying I'm gonna open this
thing back up you might have said that's
a bunch of claptrap that's not right but
finally somebody was fighting for people
who felt that their their dignity had
been attenuated so what are we gonna do
about that I mean if Donald Trump is a
coercive leader is ultimately not
successful in his bid I mean look he's
got the best economy in decades and his
popularity isn't very high I'm not gonna
say I'm not a political prognosticator
I'm not a meteorologist in the in the in
the in the and the weather of politics
but but I don't I don't know what's
gonna happen but whether he's successful
or not successful we have to take a
lesson about dignity from this and that
comes from making every single person
needed you want a good policy it makes
people more
you want a terrible policy it makes
people less needed less needed their
families which is to say that it splits
families apart to create incentives for
that lesson to their communities by
fragmenting our communities and and most
importantly in the case that we've seen
over the past ten years unnecessary the
economy by by creating a sentence for
idleness by making it harder to find
jobs this is the Oracle on how to bring
dignity back and to how to fix this
situation for the United States well one
of the this is a fascinating debate to
me because what I've seen is that
there's sort of this continuum when it
comes to the dignity gap and the power
of work ranging from Tucker Carlson on
sort of the populist I would almost a
left to Orin Cassie somewhere in the
middle loosely the Tucker Carlson's on
the puppy was left yeah I mean he sat in
the chair that you're currently sitting
in and pop in and he legitimately said
that he would outlaw self-driving cars
in order to preserve in order to
preserve jobs for people who are driving
trucks for example yeah I and he's been
he spoken in his book his new book he
talks a lot about regulation of the
economy specifically in order to prevent
technological progress because he
believes that they're a group of people
who are going to be put out of work by
that technological progress that policy
is almost indistinguishable in certain
runs from Bernie Sanders's policy right
and so when it comes to when it comes to
Tucker on cultural issues of the
populous right when it comes to issues
of economics and regulation he's in many
ways closer to the populace that's it's
kind of fascinating then you have folks
like Loren cast or kind of in the
populist middle right who have suggested
regulatory reform but he's also
suggested the idea of a certain amount
of redistribution ISM where do you where
do you fall along these lines I mean how
do we cure this problem because it seems
to me that we we maybe if we feel we're
in a transformative moment if we feel
that we're in a moment where technology
is obviating an enormous number of jobs
for people who don't graduate from
college all right it then is the
solution to that redistribution ISM is
that a solution to that regulation or is
the solution to that maybe something
else which is for the first time in a
long time
returning to finding meaning in
something other than simply going to a
factory and doing a job yeah okay so
this is I'm not a populist I'm I'm not
trying to rhyme here I'm an optimist I'm
an optimist about what can actually
happen in this country look we've had
wave after wave of technological change
we've had wave after wave
way that jobs are sorted the way that
they break up the way that they're
reformulated and one thing I'm just not
willing to accept is that people
actually can't see labor markets and
skills and new ways this is America I
mean the whole idea that somehow it's
either no skills and desperation and
trying to you know hit the brakes on
technology so the self-driving cars are
somehow illegal or you have to go to
college Lister that's an insane
dichotomy as far as I'm concerned the
truth is we've lacked imagination in
this country because we have a
completely screwed up educational system
we have an educational system that is
great as serving guys like Ben and
Arthur and it's really really bad at
serving people who have all kinds of
visual spatial skills you know it's it's
crazy that our standardized testing in
this country it looks at verbal and
quantitative but it doesn't look at
visual spatial skills like I got a kid a
teenage kid he's turning 19 this year
his name is Carlos he loves you he's
watching this right now Carlos graduated
from high school he didn't want to go to
college he wanted to go to work so he
went to work on a farm in Idaho and he
is thriving he's getting up at five
o'clock in the morning during harvest
he's driving a five hundred thousand
dollar combine he's doing stuff that I
can't even imagine it amazes me I'm so
proud of him well I'm his dad I could
kind of help him make his way into so
that he could earn his own success but
not everybody is in a family where those
opportunities exist why don't we have a
country that that has the imagination to
say that not everybody's cut from the
same mold that if you don't go to
college you're somehow a loser that's
nuts what we need to actually do is to
beef up the vocational and technical
education system in this country so it's
just as important as going to college we
need a an apprenticeship system that we
could experiment with and state and
local level there's all kinds of policy
solutions to this but the cultural
question is the biggest one of all which
is actual respect and dignity that goes
to people who don't have college
education because they have so much to
bring look here's the key stat not that
three million people are going to be
thrown out of jobs when we have
self-driving cars but we have seven
million unfilled jobs in this country
today
look I go to places in Eastern Kentucky
we just show this documentary film
partly in a place called Inez Kentucky
where President Johnson kicked off the
war on poverty and you see unemployed
people next to unfilled jobs I talked to
people in manufacturing all the time who
they
can't find workers what's up with that
that's not because we have too much
technology it's not because we have to
make it illegal to innovate I'm like on
work doesn't matter how much you make it
illegal it's gonna happen one way or the
other we have to embrace it and we have
to skill up and we need an educational
system that treats people with equal
dignity whether they go to Harvard or
not and this is one of the areas where I
really think that it gets into
uncomfortable tension because a lot of
folks in conservative and leftist
circled liberal circles they focus a lot
on what the government can do to make
these things happen and seems to me the
vast majority this stuff has to be done
through social fabric and when I say
social fabric half the time I think I'm
using a euphemism for religious
community because the truth is that
there were a couple of factors that I
think were here three generations ago
that are that are no longer here one of
them is the belief that there's a
community that is larger than you that
is going to help take care of you if God
forbid something happens to you and
government has been used as a substitute
for that and the other is that you know
that that community exists not just in
your city meaning that you know when I
was talking to Tucker and I thought it's
a fascinating conversation because
Tucker took the position that you should
never have to move from your hometown he
said should you really have to move from
the place where your grandparents are
buried and I said well you know there is
this biblical call to Abraham and the
the just in the Joseph Campbell hero's
journey every every journey starts with
somebody calling you to adventure so
America was always about that call to
adventure but the call to adventure
exists largely because I as a Jew I can
pick up and I can move to anywhere I
know that there's a Jewish community and
I can walk into somebody's house and I
know that they're going to be able to
take care of me they're gonna help me
out because we share a certain
fundamental a certain fundamental fabric
together and I think that it's broader
than my social community my Jewish
community I think that it extends also
to many religious Christians I think
that extends to conservatives but in the
absence of that social fabric I think
it's gonna be very difficult to build
the sense of comfort that you can move
somewhere and start anew so how do we
rebuild some of these key components
because we live in a time when people
have the greatest ease of travel we've
ever had in human history when as you
say there are lots of jobs available to
people who want them and people are not
moving when there's this almost fuel of
malaise to use a Carter phrase that is
set over the country where we feel like
we're in a dying community and if we
tell people to pick up and move from
those commuter
that's a political loser right telling
people to pick up and move from those
communities if you tell people the best
decision you can make is to graduate
high school and then get any job that
you can possibly get and don't have a
baby out of wedlock this is considered
by a lot of folks in American politics
to be discriminatory and terrible right
and you know for those of us who are
kind of freedom based folks it's like
the personal decisions come first I
wonder if there's a fundamental
disconnect about the picture of the
country itself that is that is gonna be
difficult to bridge yeah it's it's
really tricky one of the things that
we've forgotten both on the political
right and the political left I mean that
the political right has been has become
pretty libertarian or the past few and I
got nothing against my friends who were
libertarians but you got to remember
that that stuff does not work unless the
the fundamental moral code is existing
underneath it I mean morals come before
markets I mean Adam Smith wrote The
Wealth of Nations seventeen years after
the Theory of Moral Sentiments I mean he
believed that we're we're not dignified
we can't handle a market system unless
we actually have our morals together
that we understand and serve each other
that we have a concept of a greater
purpose that's the reason you thought
that the Theory of Moral Sentiments was
a better book a more important book than
the wealth of nations he went back to at
the end of his life and worked on it you
know what we've forgotten in this
country on the political right and left
but especially in the political right is
we're all wealthy nations no Theory of
Moral Sentiments we have to remember
that none of this stuff works I mean you
know capitalism is a machine it's a good
machine it's a great machine it's the
best machine for pulling out upon people
out of poverty in the history of mankind
but like any other machine it can be
used for you know Mal purposes it can
you can it's like a car you can drive it
to work and support your family or or
you can drive it into your you get drunk
and drive it in your neighbors living
room and run over them while they're
watching television hurt them I mean
it's a you know capitalism actually
requires morals and this is the thing
that we have to remember so therefore
what I would like to encourage people
are watching us to remember is that in
America in an entrepreneurship based
society we're not just looking for the
next innovation that's going to make us
richer we have to be looking for the the
resurgence of our ideas through social
entrepreneurship that will bring our
culture back but really great
entrepreneurs should be doing spiritual
entrepreneurs cultural entrepreneurs
people there that are thinking about
what the gears should be
for a really great America and by that I
don't mean a richer America just a more
prosperous America I mean a a healthier
country we're more happier where people
want to live people want to raise their
kids where people have a greater sense
of adventure where they have a greater
sense of community that requires the
best minds watching us right now to
think about themselves as the
entrepreneurs that are gonna truly bring
the country back that does not
necessarily mean developing an app what
that means is developing a congregation
maybe and that's the kind of
entrepreneurship man if we if we got
back to that idea that by the way is the
Entrepreneurship that made America what
it is today between the Civil War in the
First World War that's the the
self-improvement and the tent revival
and that and that and the temperance and
the abolitionist spirits that went into
the social entrepreneurship that that
made it into a congenial environment
that that drew your great-grandparents
here that's where they're not in some
town in the Ukraine that's why they are
in the United States and if we want to
get people to courage we have to create
the ecosystem that will will inspire
their courage if we want them to get a
u-haul instead of just being depressed
about what's going on we have to create
an environment where they have that kind
of confidence just the kind of
confidence that you're talking about and
that requires the innovative spirit the
frontier spirit that we've kind of lost
in this country we got to get back
soin ask a base political question cuz
we haven't done any base politics at
this point so I want to ask you you talk
about the distinction seeing
conservative and libertarian and how
much of a social welfare state there
should be what is your what is your
ideal what do you think should should
the social welfare state look like and
full disclosure I tend toward the more
libertarian on this my view is that you
know the vast majority of social welfare
should be done at the at the
non-governmental level by religious
communities ideally and then if there
are people who fall through the cracks
that's where local government comes in
then state government then federal
government but you talk about sort of
the the certain levers that you think
that we can tweak in Social Welfare
where do you see the ideal social
welfare state being what do you think
that that level looks like no I mean I
could probably put dollar figures on it
we can kind of go through the
spreadsheets on it that's what we do it
that's why God created the American
Enterprise actually to come up with
dollar figures on this but but as a
philosophical principle I I have you
know pretty solid libertarian roots like
you do but they're they're they're more
morally based than practically based I
I'm not really that concerned about how
much it costs
what I'm concerned about is the Dilla
teria spill overs that happen to people
at the margins of our society and so the
key thing for me is using our policy
ideas using our intellect using the
blessings that we've got on behalf of
people with less power than Ben and
Arthur that's my view I mean that's and
that's a that's a you know it's not very
Catholic you know in this way but but by
the way where did I get these ideas we
got these ideas from the Jews you know
this idea that we exist such that we can
help people with less power than we have
that can mean a lot of different things
I I don't care that much about the money
I mean I realized that you run out of
other people's like that Cyril I said
you run out of other people's money
sooner or later what I worry about is
the extent to which we've designed
programs that do mobilize people that
hurt people that marginalize people and
leave them desperate one of my
colleagues charles murray who wrote
losing ground in 1984 he pointed this
out the problem the welfare system is
not how much it costs it's that the it's
it's an it harms the people it's
supposed to help and that's the
fundamental problem so so my
libertarianism to the extent that we can
call it that is based on that for that
for the principles how much it costs
then we're actually getting into
accounting what actually works well what
works the criterion for what works is
does it make people more needed or does
it make people less needed and welfare
programs from 1923 1964 when Lyndon
Johnson went to inés Kentucky until
today have been making people less
needed more comfortable and less needed
and that's the big scandal of that I'm
willing to spend tons of money I'm
absolutely willing to spend actually
what it takes if we have a welfare
system that will enhance the necessity
of people and as such to build up their
dignity and we're not there yet okay so
at the very end of your book love your
enemies you give a bunch of tips for
people how to actually get beyond your
own feelings about this and you know as
I say there's a there's a concept in
Judaism called muster and muster is is
the idea basically of
people trying to convince you to be
better at being a human being and that I
took this as a work of muster I'm
reading it and and I'm thinking to
myself okay how can I do better so what
are some of your tips for folks to help
love their enemies to help get beyond
ego because a lot of it is about ego
submission about saying like you know
what contempt would be the easy response
here I'll take the hit and I'm gonna try
and love you anyway yeah to begin with
the most important thing to keep in mind
is that when somebody treats you with
contempt
you have to see it as an opportunity and
this is a real mindset set shift I
learned this from our friends the the
the latter-day saints previously known
as the Mormons I mean and you know they
would they'll go on missions and it's
amazing it's like man how do you deal
with the rejection I mean it cuz you
know people are not like oh boy Mormons
on the board say no no you understand
every time that there is some rejection
that's an opportunity for us to react to
the rejection in such a way that people
are inherently morally attracted to it
so the first thing to keep in mind is
that that we have mastery over ourselves
this is the blessing you know when we're
creating God's image we're actually able
to to extend the the time between
stimulus-response you know you're
stimulated if you're true if you're
treated with contempt and you answer
just like that with contempt then the
time between stimulus and response has
been minimized because you're not the
master of yourself you can make the
decision to answer with and with
contempt but typically we don't so what
we need to do is just to take that time
say I was just treated with contempt
it's a big opportunity that's a bigger
opportunity to answer somebody with
kindness and in so doing somebody's
gonna see it it's gonna change my heart
and I'm never gonna go away saying you
know what I wish I would been more of a
jerk that's not what so that's principle
number one now principle number two is
rebellion and you know it's it's funny
it's one of the things that I I take a
lot of my writing and a lot of my
thinking from Saul Alinsky actually he
was a very clever guy his politics were
all messed up as far as I'm concerned he
was wrong on most things but he was
really good on communication on and and
is very clever in a lot of ways and one
of the things that he did in a lot of
things that people on the political left
have done from time immemorial is to
stand up to the man is to have a sense
of the man what we need to do that right
now - I mean again not to treat anybody
with contempt even the man but to
remember that seven percent of Americans
are profiting from the current
environment now I say this with
appropriate humility because sometimes
it's been me and I don't want it to be
me and that's why I've written a book
and that's why we're having this
conversation it's why I'm so grateful
that we get to talk about it because we
have
been perfect but we want to be better
ninety-three percent of Americans want
to be better they don't want the current
climate of contempt all the people who
are unrepentant about this who are
getting rich and powerful and famous and
getting clicks and making money and
getting elected office that seven
percent we need to leave behind I mean
it's time for us to to turn that off and
to think about what we can actually do
to lift other people up and here's the
third one here's the third one here's
the one that it's really capturing my
imagination we have to go what we're not
invited and say things that people don't
expect that's the sort of the missionary
spirit that's why I admire you you're
unafraid and you go places where I mean
technically you're invited by the
college Republicans but you're not
invited I mean let's be honest when
you're going on to a lot of these
college campuses there's a hostile
environment and the truth is they don't
understand you I mean I've heard your
message for years you're not coming in a
spirit of hostility and contempt on the
contrary you're talking about big issues
and you're trying to explain things and
coherent terms and they represent
something we're all kind of these days
and modern American polarized politics
we're just abot ours for something else
right but but you're not invited but
you're going anyway and you're going in
a spirit of adventure and and you're
always happy I can tell because you're
having yeah of course you do and look I
write about happiness I know the tells I
can tell that you're happy to be there
that's a really really good thing what
we need more is people who have this
spirit of the missionary they want to be
there even though they haven't been
haven't been invited and they're gonna
say things that people don't expect not
more hostile not more outrageous than
people expected but more loving and not
agreeing but more loving than people
expected and I'll leave you this one
image that's really stuck with me lately
and I closed the book with this because
it had such a big impact on me you know
I was at my wife and I we do we do
marriage prep we teach marriage prep for
you know 25 or 30 couples over a couple
of months in in a Catholic retreat
center near our home and it's really
super inspirational because these these
guys are I mean they're in it they're
gonna get married for the rest are alive
til death do us part and and we're just
given a little bit of our wisdom because
we've been doing it for a long time and
and we were in this Chapel of this
marriage retreat center and I noticed
the sign over the door but not a sign
when you're going in it's a sign for
people who are in the chapel going out
into the parking lot it's the last thing
you see when you leave this chapel and
it said you are now entering mission
territory myself that's not a religious
message necessarily that's that's been
and Arthur in our public ministry look
we have one life we have one career we
have one set of opportunities to get out
there and spread what's right and true
your book does this your book actually
says this is a gift share the gift if I
if I were to summarize because I got to
read the book before anybody watching
got to read the book right that this is
our gift and we get to share it embrace
it with love and happiness and with
affection and with positivity that's
that's as far as I'm concerned that's
the point your book that's what we can
do with our public ministry and all the
things that we talked about as well get
out there remember that when you go out
of the house and you're talking to
friends and you're talking to me people
who disagree with you you're in mission
territory don't mess it up nobody Kicks
down the door and threatens somebody
unless they join the church they try to
make it beautiful and they try to make
it good and that's what we can that's
what I can certainly be better at that's
what I'm dedicating the rest of my life
to doing so I have to ask you because
you famously you've been famous vegan
for a long time how did the vegan I have
to ask you this because I've been
getting this question more and more on
college campuses and I really do think
that in a hundred years when their
actual appropriate meat alternatives for
children there's gonna be one of those
areas where 100 years people are gonna
look back and say used to kill animals
for food no raise them to how long
that's insane how did you become vegan
how did that happen my wife so my wife
is almost I mean all good things in my
life come from my wife
I mean it's it's you know everything
I've learned about love everything you
learned about my Catholic faith all that
stuff comes my way and my wife
experiments with different no diets from
time to time and I have to say it was
kind of bother me I mean eating it again
I can let you know this is I'm gonna get
a ton of emails but I got to do some
warmth toward veganism you know it's
gonna be some at NIMH just because and
I'm less saying that's nobody should eat
meat and and that people shouldn't raise
animals and people shouldn't I mean fine
but for me I felt more comfortable
getting my sources of protein and giving
getting my nutrition from plant sources
that for a bunch of different reasons
both health and an ethical reasons
and so I tried it and I gotta tell you
man I feel great great all the time I
mean it's it's weird I'm 54 years old I
feel better than I did when I was 24
years old and part of the reason is
because I'm living I was a musician then
it's Elissa suffice it to say in living
a healthier lifestyle you know the pack
of cigarettes not there that's good too
you know among other things but yeah I
find that I I feel like I'm in my 20s I
feel great all the time has something to
do with my with my diet my exercise and
and I recommend it anybody wants to try
it I think it's a I think it's really
good I would recommend it to you at
least try it for a month okay so I and
one finally the two guys on the right
we're vegan I know it and then we'll
immediately lose our jobs and baby so I
have one more question for you I want to
ask you where you going next because you
were at AEI and now you're moving on I
want to ask about that first if you want
to hear Arthur Brooks his answer
you have to be a subscriber at daily
wire to go subscribe it's daily where I
go to daily where calm click on that
subscribe button you can hear the end of
our conversation over there the book
itself is amazing you should go buy it
love your enemies by Arthur Brooks
thanks so much for stopping by I really
appreciate your time thank you been
[Music]
avenged shop hero shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and Guillot
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]